This is the keyword to answer the question of core values of the first
bumlak a that is trustworthy means to hold firmly the trust given.
The second competent is to continue to learn and develop capabilities.
Three harmonious means caring for each other and respecting differences.
Loyal means dedicated and prioritizes the interests of the nation and state.
5.
Adaptive is constantly innovating and enthusiastic
in moving or facing the 6th change.
Collaborative means building synergistic cooperation.
For example,
it s inside.
This book is equipped with the latest answer and discussion key.
Well if you want to pass please check out the
book in the yellow basket right now.